[Music]
I've been so blessed with such an
amazing career and you know from crazy
Rich Asians from memos of a Geisha to
everything everywhere all at once and
when you finally get a script where a
character that was so ordinary and how
we are able to make her extraordinary I
was very very touched
I did have someone say are you sure
about this because this is very diff
that's the point it is different and I'm
always saying I want to be able to do
more and be challenged and this one
challenged me I don't think we could
have done it with anybody else there is
no everything everywhere without
Michelle Young
so the scene that we're watching is the
moment when Evelyn has hit her rock
bottom
she thinks everything I do is wrong
Evelyn being a mother wife immigrant
it's a life that's very overwhelming she
cares so much about everything but she
can't actually give the attention that
in these relationships need hey Evelyn
bagel
and writes when she is about to lose
Faith her husband comes in
you can still turn around and avoid all
this
be kind
too late to win
don't say that
this is the moment I think in the script
it said something about Michelle sees
her husband for the first time for
everything that he is it's it's a moment
where she stops and looks at her husband
after kind of ignoring him for you know
about an hour of the movie
did you see that
that was what she suddenly reflected on
in I think in the depths of her heart as
she watched inside her her own head the
images of them getting together buying
the new laundromat starting a new life
having a kid and those were precious
precious moments that we tend to forget
set up this lighting rig and aimed it at
Michelle and just told her you know
sorry you're not going to be able to act
opposite key but imagine you're looking
at your husband and finally seeing him
you know it's a very vague bit of
direction and she just gave this
performance like I don't know if we did
two takes and we were like tearing up at
the monitor such a testament to her
insane ability as an actress she's just
looking into a camera lens
and telling communicating this story
with her eyes and those little giggles
and smiles as she just starts to well up
and I remember like both of us at the
monitor being like oh this scene's gonna
work and then we turn it around and we
pointed at a key and he did the same
thing
In This Moment Wayman becomes the key to
how Evelyn figures out what really
matters
[Music]
when we were in downtown L.A in an alley
uh shooting that movie Style universe
uh it was quite surreal to me because I
got the pleasure of working for Wonka y
behind the camera
and who we are and dedicating an entire
universe
so for me because I haven't done acting
for for so long putting on that suit
having my hair slick back and stepping
in front of the camera it was emotional
to me
walking very closely with key he fitted
the road it's so brilliant and we need
fabulous access like this
there are the homages to one car y in
the mood for love but also references
Michelle yo the actress for me I wanted
to have her be more Michelle than Evelyn
in that scene I asked Michelle who do
you like to wear on the red carpet she
had suggested some brands that she liked
and one of them was Illy Saab and they
had graciously sent some dresses for us
to borrow the one that we see is the one
that we thought worked the best for the
scene
foreign
[Music]
written by the Daniels in another life
and I would have just loved doing taxes
and laundry with you it was very
memorable
this scene is extremely pivotal to the
movie this line of dialogue that women
delivers to her was so important to us
for so many drafts for years we like
built the movie knowing that like at
this point he's going to say this line
to her
I feel like this scene is something that
sets up the rest of the film The Final
climax which is basically her taking
this lesson and trying her best to give
the people around her the love and
attention that she had been withholding
for most of her life
there are over 100 cues of Music in this
movie which is a lot a lot a lot of
music for for a film
the laundry and taxes queue which
continues through that scene and gets
bigger and bigger that was one of the
most tricky scenes to score because it
was so significant a moment emotionally
that just called for a kind of effusive
like a giving in to The Melancholy and
the sweetness
[Music]
Stephanie Shu comes from Comedy and
Broadway and she loves improv and so she
was perfect for the role of jobu playing
jobu and joy simultaneously was one of
the most interesting and complex
characters I've ever played and also
most fun because you really get to
stretch your range so wide because you
start as this very understated daughter
and you know like as an actor or a
dramaturg or director you know that that
daughter who is so invisible is about to
become an
Ultra nihilist chaos Creator villain
and it's really quite vulnerable I feel
like to be a woman and as grotesque and
just kind of let it all hang out the way
that the Daniels wanted jobu to be I do
think it spoke to the themes of the film
of a daughter who terrifies her mother
Mrs Wang are you with us
so this is the first time we meet Jamie
Lee Curtis's character Deirdre she is
the auditor assigned to the Wong family
need I remind you that there's already a
lien on your property repossession is
well within our rights I know I am
paying attention right before this
moment Evelyn Michelle's character has
just discovered that she is connected to
another version of herself hiding in the
closet and so she is completely
distracted she has no idea what's going
on and the genre line is starting to
blur
nothing
but a stack of receipts I can trace the
ups and downs of your lives
and it does not look good
it does not look good
sorry my wife confuses her hobbies for
businesses
an honest mistake at that moment she was
like you're supposed to be on my side
and she was hurt and the thing is all
these little moments that when every
time you don't hear you feel that he's
not with her it's against her and that
you know as a couple that's the worst
thing that you can do because it just
like adds next time it adds a little bit
more the end of it when she suddenly
goes to another Universe she's like it
was so beautiful there you know why am I
coming back to this
well with all of these um honest
mistakes I mean even if we don't charge
you with
fraud will most certainly have to find
you for
gross negligence
you're always trying to confuse us with
these big words
I know deirdre's I think Deirdre
represents forgotten people who are
doing jobs that are awful that have lost
their Humanity in their jobs Jamie
showed up early and just redecorated her
own cubicle she was like no my cats
would go here and and she figured out
where the file folders would go and she
spent quite a while a little baggie
filled with Deirdre pops and oh yeah she
had her own things she had her perfume
picked out and she was like Deirdre
where's this perfume
truth of the matter is that was day one
and two of the whole movie and I arrived
fully formed I'm not someone who is
going to discover it in the process of
the shooting
this is a character that could have been
like a smaller role and because of her
presence she transformed it into
something that you know is we're still
talking about now
[Music]
I found that this movie it's very
interesting how every person takes
something quite different from it and I
think that's why it's generation so much
love
you know it's a movie about distractions
and we live in a world where we're
constantly distracted by so many things
and one of the only things we have to
give each other is our attention the
entire reason why we wrote this film was
we were grappling with the question of
how do we exist in the chaos and the
noise of Modern Life you know like how
do you make sense of any of it there's
zero sense that they don't know exactly
what the shot is exactly what they need
and they are a beautiful combo we wanted
to create a movie that would stand up
against all the big Blockbusters in
theaters but then also be a sort of an
argument for saying that the small
intimate moments in our lives are just
as big as those moments and not get
washed away this movie has a wonderful
theme it's about kindness It's about
empathy it's about acceptance and it
came out just the right time the
heartbeat of this film is so big that if
it does catch you it feels really good
to feel
it is so grounded by a real emotion that
is love that is compassion that's
kindness it's okay we will be there for
each other
[Music]